hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we are going to be making one of
my most favorite drinks I've never tried
to make this before but this is a
non-alcoholic mojito
have you guys been enjoying my summer
snacks week and this is actually our
last episode so I'm really sad about it
but no better way to save cheers to the
freakin weekend and have you some fun
than a mojito a virgin
okey doke non-alcoholic if you choose to
make it alcoholic that is not my problem
you do what you want so the items that
we're gonna need for said mojito is
simple syrup sparkling water
--eline mint ice we need ice we also
need cups to put this in pumps you'll
see hi to everybody hello it's naughty
you're so handsome
go get Jenna I don't know how to muddle
I mean I've seen them go to bars before
you just kind of go hey so we need a
sprig a sprig of mint this is looks like
a sprig to me
well sprig DUP Smit got a smells brain
making too so we need to just really get
rowdy
half of a lime sliced well this is half
of the lime I sliced it
are you nuts slicing so I'm just gonna
squeeze this lime in here just go
squeeze this lime I'm just going to
squeeze the lime into the root this is a
lot of muddle it this muddling 1
tablespoon of simple syrup feel like my
muddling was not not good I got carded
for buying this simple syrup so I'm
going to use this bottom of this ice
cream scooper to just really get in
there this muddle away I'm actually
working quite nicely there are some of
those in there looks real good
now we add a little sparkling water mmm
that looks good
just mix it up real good bandy got a
freaking lime wedge just like that is
that how you do it exactly you show it
on area this one actually looks a little
bit cuter can do like one of the layup
mm-hmm now it's time to try it let's
give it a shot
whoo it's actually surprisingly minty
it's very nice and refreshing it's
really good actually
I guess I'll bring one to Jenna anyway
hey you want to try this Oh Donna where
she's at
anyway I hope you guys enjoyed summer
snack week I had so much fun making
these videos for you guys I hope you
enjoyed it and thank you again for 3
million subscribers here on YouTube it's
been such a fun ride and I can't wait
for more fun things in the future so
here's to freaking weekend but don't
have me some fun
see you later mmm house nice nice taste
no more rushing